who do you think took back shots better
me or Tom we should get it back to John
we really should get a back-to-back yo
the pictures I
like ice cream you can just tell from
your face
was quivering and [__] like you was
really enjoy
ing time he was taking that [__] you
wanted it rough you wanted it like like
forceful but you wanted it was weird
what Lottery
but that [__] Oscar now that's crazy bro
so that's exactly how you look no you
never said dude in me man you never saw
dude in me
boss can you try to find that you never
saw the dude in me all right this is
what this is what Tommy did no but try
to find oh [__] dude
come on bruh dude come on dude let's go
why is everything gay now you feel the
Brick Oven yeah dude I do feel broken
and more intimate look they're locking
hands yeah okay yeah we got it we gotta
go he's just a better actor that's all
yeah
you ain't really get into it bro now
that I'm saying you're not gay enough
yeah take that I'm not I mean if you're
gonna be a gay for a role you might as
well be an actor yeah I mean don't know
how many times they shot that bro
s
how many times do you ever do anything
in one take I let them bring the stuff I
did that I did I was like nah you need
to stunt double this [__] right here I
heard you was fluffing them before
though that's crazy
[Laughter]
they are wiping my gay from the internet
thank you shout out
but you're doing pretty good stuff when
it comes to me being gay
are you saying hey I thought you meant
non-binary people and I was like how we
come to this no no they are there's two
days they're the people in control of
everything and the people in control of
everything
come on what was the name of that movie
we thought of this [__] here's John it
was a team there's Johnny oh they are
their theirs
it was on
what was that [__] that got canceled
Hulu now it's Hulu now Hulu bought it
but it was originally for this streaming
service
I forgot what it was they why don't you
turn the phone to me
nothing
no it's for another [__] thing I
forgot what it was we're gonna find
we'll react to that live yeah anyway